you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme a rapid analysis of
the north american heatwave finds
climate change
did play a part we hear how the united
states will need to adapt to the new
normal
how the world's most climate vulnerable
countries aim to tackle the crisis and
promote economic growth
and from sea grass to kelp forests we
find out more about the projects using
nature
to help protect the planet
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and we're going to start today
at
our data dashboard and the numbers that
are affecting our planet
right now and let's show you this number
it's an estimate of just how much hotter
the earth is compared with
pre-industrial levels and at the moment
we're just over 1.2 degrees of warming
now that increase means
record temperatures and extreme weather
events are becoming more common
well last month was the hottest june
ever in north america
and today new analysis should suggest
the record high temperatures
would have been virtually impossible
without climate change
a rapid analysis of the heat wave by an
international team of climate scientists
found global warming driven by human
activity
made it at least 150 times more likely
to happen
so let's remind you of some of the
numbers and before last week's heatwave
in the north
we were already seeing extreme heat and
drought in states in the southwest
of the u.s now phoenix in arizona
hit a record of 46 degrees for five
consecutive days
in june while in california
palm springs tied with its all-time
temperature record of just over
50 degrees then last week in oregon the
city of
portland reached a record of 46.6
degrees now the average temperature for
that time of year would normally see
highs of around 26.
seattle in the state of washington set a
new record with a high of more than
42 degrees celsius while the all-time
canadian record was broken
with litten in british columbia
recording a temperature
of nearly 50 degrees well above the
country's previous national record
of 45 degrees celsius well our u.s
correspondent greg milam is in los
angeles for us now and greg
are these record high temperatures
affecting attitudes towards climate
change
i think they are the fact that these
were so unusual the fact that they were
so much hotter than the previous records
so much hotter than people had actually
predicted
is forcing people to take more notice
and what the researchers are looking at
is whether there's a bigger
shift than they thought in unexpected
places so like the pacific northwest and
those those numbers you mentioned there
because they say
until now a heatwave like this has been
considered something like a one in a one
thousand year event
but with current trends they say by the
2040s
it could be an event that happens every
5 to 10 years and that's why they're
sounding these
these warnings and scientists who
involved in this research
say the message from it is very clear
the most important thing we need to do
is stop
burning fossil fuels um as fast
as possible because as long as we emit
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere the
atmosphere gets warmer
and so these dramatic heat waves become
even more intense
and more likely but we also need to be
better prepared we need to change how
our cities are designed
because if you have lots of green spaces
in the city
the temperatures don't get quite as hot
and and so that that's a very important
adaptation measure that we also need to
take
because heat waves are how climate
change
manifests today so that's on governments
of course uh the biden administration
has been talking about climate again
today they have a very different
approach as we know from from his
predecessor
in the white house and they say the
focus should be on heat related deaths
they estimate hundreds possibly
thousands of people died as a result
of that heat wave we've just seen uh
heat is the the biggest weather related
killer
in the us more than wildfires more than
hurricanes and they say that's something
we need to focus on because there is
another heat wave coming
in the next few days not as extreme but
they say it's something we're going to
have to get used to
greg thank you in today's other climate
news a court has declared the australian
government
must protect young people from harmful
carbon dioxide emissions
if a new coal mine is approved a judge
found the country's environment minister
susan
lay must take reasonable care to avoid
causing personal injury or death to
australian residents under the age of
18.
climate has changed the size of our
bodies according to new research
the university of cambridge study
analyzed 300 fossils
and found colder climates drive the
evolution of
larger bodies while warmer climates lead
to smaller bodies
it suggests that as global warming
brings higher temperatures
humans could evolve to become smaller to
adapt
and people are finding themselves in
increasing conflict with wild animals
the world wildlife fund says the rising
demand for space
aggravated by climate change and habitat
loss
means more species are being forced to
cohabit with humans
it's led to animals like elephants and
cheetahs being killed in self-defense or
to protect livestock
which puts them at risk of extinction
getting countries to work together to
tackle climate change is an essential
part of addressing the climate crisis
today bangladesh hosted this year's v20
finance summit bringing together
governments with the aim of transforming
economic activities
while keeping global warming below 1.5
degrees
and also allowing growth in the world
economy well joining me now from dakar
is abu kalam
azad special envoy of the climate
vulnerable
forum welcome to you so what have you
been calling for
at this v20 summit the
main agenda for this summit is
recovery for the sustainable prosperity
and also innovative financing for the
climate prosperity
uh called on by the honourable prime
minister
by putting a climate prosperity plan
uh for bangladesh uh which we call the
music climate prosperity plan
and this will act as template for all
the cbf country
where she called for having a climate
prosperity plan
in all the cbf countries
and how important is assistance from the
rest of the world
back in 2009 a promise was made that a
hundred billion dollars a year would be
given to developing countries to help
them tackle climate change
that pledge still hasn't been met and
it's overdue
how much faith do you have that that
help will come
this 100 billion dollar per year
uh paris agreement it is not fulfilled
again
so now from this summit we are raising
our voice
that uh in next five years 500 billion
who is going to contribute how much
where you are going to put this money
please come up with a specific program
for these vulnerable countries
so we're going to raise this voice from
now and we're going to take this to the
cup 26 also well apple callum azad it's
good to talk to you thanks very much
indeed
thank you now i'm sure everyone was
glued to the climate show last night but
apparently there was also a football
match on as well
and as the nation stopped to watch
england beat denmark it had an
impact on how much power we were using
now here you can see the demand on a
normal first day evening there in yellow
and then the demand on the grid last
night now electricity usage was actually
lower than usual because everyone
stopped doing all their normal
energy-intensive activities
and focused on the game but however
there were
three spikes in demand that you can see
there they're all lining up with breaks
during the match
now at half time there was a pickup in
demand of 1
400 megawatts now that's the equivalent
of boiling 777
777 kettles and there were also peaks at
full time
and at the end of extra time as well now
last night 44
of electricity generated came from
fossil fuels and 16
from renewable sources and that figure
was low
because of calm wind and also because
the match was on in the evening
there was less solar generation and you
can see a full
breakdown of where electricity in great
britain is coming from at any time you
like
just head to skynews.com climate
now small changes can make a big
difference to our environment and it's
hoped that
12 new high-impact nature-based
solutions
will help tackle the climate crisis now
the projects
include restoring thousands of hectares
of peatlands in northern england
peat is an amazing way to store carbon
naturally saving more than 8
000 tons of carbon dioxide per hectare
every year
a project by essex wildlife trust to
restore and protect the uk
salt marshes will be expanded now they
act as a massive carbon sink as well as
reducing
flood risks and the effects of storm
surges
and sea grass can capture carbon up to
35
times faster than tropical rainforests
but 90 percent of uk sea grass meadows
have been lost
and it's hoped that a project in the
solent will help restore them and
improve biodiversity in the process
well dr tim ferreiro is a senior marine
biologist at the hampshire and isle of
wight
wildlife trust who are responsible for
that project he joins me now
dr ferrero tell us a little bit more
about what you're doing there then
hello anna yes well we're very lucky
down here on the south coast in the
solent to have
some of the best and most important
remaining
seagrass meadows in the country and
we know in the soland from anecdotal
records that
we too have lost a tremendous amount of
seagrass
over the last 100 years and
seagrass does have this amazing ability
to capture
carbon and tremendous other ecosystem
benefits as well
and so our project which is the solan
sea restoration project
which we're doing actually in
partnership with boscardis westminster
and supported by the people's postcode
lottery
we are looking at ways that we can
actually
give nature a help and help to restore
some of our lost sea grass
so it has an important function in
capturing
carbon but also what could it do locally
to the habitat
well yes as as a carbon capture
obviously it's a plant it takes in
carbon dioxide
into its leaves and roots and stores
that but
a really important feature of seagrass
is its habitat function
so as seagrass goes through a seagrass
meadow you can see one behind me here
uncovered by the tides it slows down the
sea water
and lots of particles and organic
material drop out
and they sink down into the sediment and
are buried
that's a really important part of the
carbon capture function
of a sea grass meadow but also
it does things like purify water
and that process of of slowing down
currents
absorbs wave energy so seagrasses
amazingly have have a
an impact on our coastal protection dr
tim ferrero thanks very much indeed
you're welcome well that's everything
from us for today tomorrow find out more
about the once in a lifetime
opportunity for teenagers to explore
antarctica
thanks for watching and see you then